bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur lcp
public sénat bonjour michael schroeder
seller de parlement hebdo la semaine
politique et parlementaire commenté par
notre invité est notre invité cette
semaine thierry montons bonjour bonjour
secrétaire d'état a changé de
l'enseignement supérieur de la recherche
alors on a beaucoup d'actualité pour
vous bien évidemment on évoquera pour
commencer la situation de la gauche qui
est en plein désarroi à la proche de
l'élection présidentielle la question
d'une candidature de françois hollande
fait douter de plus en plus on verra ça
dans notre émission à l'assemblée il y a
eu ce coup de théâtre dans l'hémicycle
les députés ont refusé de taxes et
l'économique collaboratif contre l'avis
du gouvernement mais la mesure a
finalement été votée à l'issue d'une
deuxième délibération dans le cadre du
budget de la sécurité sociale semaine
marquée également par l'évacuation du
camp de calais pour bernard cazeneuve
situation est sous contrôle mais
maintenant bien le problème se pose un
peu partout en france mais surtout à
paris et avant de vous faire réagir
tirer mandon à toute cette actualité je
vous propose d'abord de commencer cette
émission par cette image manifestations
mercredi
ok de l'assemblée de policiers venus
dire leur colère et leur manque de
moyens pour accomplir leur mission
pendant ce temps dans l'hémicycle
premier ministre a appelé tout le monde
à la sagesse écoutez vous en face c'est
vrai un problème d'autorité c'est pas un
sujet nouveau
rappelons nous des émeutes de 2005 mais
autorités de l'enseignement autorités du
policier autorités du gendarme parfois
même autorité de l'élu je pense au maire
il ya une contestation plus général de
l'autorité
et puis par ailleurs rien une violence
dans la société moi ce qui me frappe
depuis quelques années c'est aussi l'élu
d'un quartier populaire des quartiers
populaires d'evry qui vous parle c'est
qu'on est passé à autre chose
aujourd'hui on veut tuer des policiers
enfin la place des policiers
elle est d'abord non pas dans la rue je
veux le dire non pas avec des cagoules
et j'en appelle moi aussi à ce moment là
ou là les discussions que nous allons
avoir parce que c'est nécessaire à ce
que chape chacun vraiment respectent la
loi
la place des policiers n'est pas dans la
rue avec des cagoules qu'est-ce que
comment vous avez pris 7 cette phrase du
premier ministre tirreno placer une
propos de bon sens c'est d'évidence
policiers quand ils sont dans la rue
c'est qu'ils font leur travail ils
manifestent et donc c'est qu'il ya des
problématiques et des problèmes à gérer
et ensuite il peut y avoir ici ou là des
tentations de l'instrumentation donc il
faut prendre les mouvements des
radiations instrumentalisation vous
voyez vous la manoeuvre nationale comme
l'a dit jean christophe cambadélis ou
pas moi je vois d'abord les problèmes
objectifs ayant la instrumentalisation
vous l'avez d'ennahda méthane et je vois
d'abord les problèmes objectifs et y en
a et ensuite que telle ou telle
sensibilité et envie d'utiliser cette
protestation pour essayer de faire
prévaloir ses thèses c'est une évidence
on l'a même vu des gens se promenaient
sur les plateaux de télévision
reporter les revendications de policiers
et on a découvert qu'il n'était pas
policier c'est donc que c'est plus
compliqué par contre les choses vernon
qui a aussi une tentative d'un type de
das motivations de ce mouvement mais ça
fait pas disparaître les problèmes
objectifs qui sont les prêts 150
millions une enveloppe contre l'afrique
question qui se pose aujourd'hui c'est
ce qu'il faut leur accorder la légitime
défense
alors là oui il ya pire cela d'abord il
ya la question des moyens ceux qui ont
été mis dans ce quinquennat ceux qui
viennent d'être ajoutés et après ils
seront à buts et ajouté autant de gens
en position sécurité absolument tentant
poste d en effectifs qu'en
investissement véhicules en matériel est
bon ça il faut tirer un enseignement de
cet effort très important qui fait
plusieurs années c'est quand on coupe
des dépenses quand on supprime des
postes dans la fonction publique
ça a des conséquences immédiates mais
pour retrouver le niveau d'efficacité
des services ça mais longtemps disons
les choses plus simplement dans le
quinquennat précédent on a supprimé des
postes on l'a baisser les crédits
d'investissement et vivian la légitime
de segi arrive c'est mieux donc voilà
c'est premièrement deuxièmement sur la
question de la légitime défense
le président de la république premier
wii sont et qui regardait de près cette
cette question c'est quand même une
justice lui est défavorable l'intérieur
est favorable il ya que ça veut dire
qu'elle est maintenant les gouvernements
ne voulons pas d'une seule voix par
définition ça veut dire que rien
arbitres avaient donc c'est la réflexion
est en cours au sein du gouvernement et
il y aura un arbitrage sur ce sujet dans
bientôt
oui j'imagine ne présentera plus qu'il a
reçus dont peu je souffre en cg avec
précaution il faut prendre de s'essuyer
avec précaution je pense que il faut pas
être trop laxistes
on laisse passer la légitime défense
c'est une notion encore une fois qui
nécessite beaucoup de rigueur dans
clients si les choses doivent évoluer ça
doit être incrémentale ces deux pas des
grosses évolutions
alors on va passer à l'actualité
parlementaire le budget de la sécurité
sociale était au menu dans l'hémicycle
et parmi les mesures qui font partie de
ce plfss comme on l'appelle la location
de biens et de services entre
particuliers
elle sera finalement taxer puisque
l'assemblée a fini par voter la mesure
hier soir après plusieurs coups de
théâtre comme nous l'expliquent céline
martel pour la location de son
appartement via une plateforme comme
airbnb un particulier devra s'affilier
au régime social des indépendants au
delà de 23000 euros par an pour la
location de biens meubles comme les
voitures ou les bateaux le gouvernement
proposait un seuil de 3860 euros un seul
doublé face aux critiques des députés
l'opposition est revenu à la charge avec
une poignée d'amendements mais en vain
qu'est ce qui va se passer
et bien vous allez avoir une partie qui
va basculer aux blacks au noir une autre
partie qui va retirer de la location
disons dans ces conditions moi je loue
pas donc on va voir une augmentation des
logements vacants
l'autre point qui a cristallisé les
débats c'est une mesure de lutte contre
les déserts médicaux avalisé en
commission des affaires sociales mais
qui a provoqué une levée de boucliers
des médecins cet amendement entendait
dissuader les médecins libéraux de
s'installer dans les zones où exercent
déjà de nombreux médecins
une mesure injuste et inefficace selon
la ministre de la santé
si ça c'est pas une médecine à deux
vitesses
je ne sais pas ce qu'est une médecine à
deux vitesses et moi je vous le dis je
ne veux pas assumer la responsabilité
historique
daoud avoir ouvert la voie à ce type de
situation l'assemblée a également voté
la hausse des taxes sur le tabac à
rouler mais à rejeter l'alignement de la
fiscalité du tabac en corse
il me paraît normal pour adoucir la vie
des corses parce que la vie est dure
il suffit pas il ne suffit pas d'y aller
au mois de juillet au mois d'août mais
en dehors de ces périodes la vie est
très dure pour les corses qu'ils aient
qu'ils bénéficient de certains avantages
fiscale ou fiscaux l'italie est à une
demi heure aussi en bateau on va donc
rétablir là
la contrebande c'est ça que vous voulez
la députée michèle delaunay a eu beau
rappeler que la mortalité des cancer du
fumeur était 25 % plus élevé encore ce
que sur le continent rappelé que la
france paierait des amendes à l'union
européenne pour sept différences de
fiscalité sur son territoire rien n'y a
fait l'examen du plfss 2010 est doit
s'achever aujourd'hui
voilà pour le résumé de josy sens on a
du mal à suivre ce qui se passe dans la
musique mais en tout cas on voit que sur
le budget de la sécurité sociale comme
sur le budget tout court par plusieurs à
plusieurs reprises le gouvernement a été
battue par sa propre majorité
quand même non c'est plus compliqué que
ça ils votent contre vote oui qu'à la
fin il a fait prévaloir ses vues et
deuxièmement on parle de débat votre
côté vous vos images le montrent très
clairement qu'il se passe devant une
poignée de 10 à 15 députés et donc là il
suffit que deux députés de la majorité
qu'ils soient partis faire un dossier
dans leur bureau je sais pas où est
et que trois de l'opposition soit arrivé
pour que les majorités change donc en
revanche ce sont mes amis non mais mais
sur le fond on est en train de perdre la
tête
on est en train de ces débats sont
absolument surréalistes ramener au
contenu vous avez la question
premièrement derby ennemis ces locations
ces locations d'appartements qui
aujourd'hui se développe de manière
absolument incroyable dans paris vous
avez des arrondissements airbnb ou c'est
pas la peine de chercher à louer vous
pourrez pas jouer puisque tout ce qu'il
sous le seul but que par hervé demi sans
aucune fiscalité mais comment peut-on
s'opposer à ce que les revenus liés à
ces locations soit en partie fiscalisés
set complètement normal mais c'est une
mais c'est une évidence et de bon sens
c'est un revenus accessoires qui retire
de la location normal ou d'aider des
appartements et donc ceux revenus des
taxes et même chose sur les déserts
médicaux poussés les médecins les
nouveaux médecins à s'installer dans les
endroits où on manque de médecins et
dissuader de s'installer à les endroits
où il ya trop de médecins
ça me semble être là encore une mesure
de bon
sens donc moi je me pose des questions
et la fiscalité le territoire national
c'est pas le sait pas mais pas morcelé
fiscalité du tabac les parts ou de
données en garde à vue le cas de la
corse
elle doit être hyper yeux partout bien
sûr c'est du sas à veauche à ce
qu'étaient les exemptions correct le
choc
encore une fois je vous dis qu'on est en
train de perdre la tête sur les
principes simples la fiscalité elle est
par définition nationale globale qui
perd la tête et des bas le débat
politique
je pense qu à une dérégulation
aujourd'hui du débat politique a promis
plein aussi quand même dans l'hémicycle
paye un problème de il ya peu de
parlementaires mais ça c'est les fin de
session parlementaire de fin de
quinquennat c'est toujours un peu
compliqué cette semaine on a aussi voté
le budget global sur les recettes en
tout cas vous êtes satisfait goût du
budget qui vous a été allouée on se
rappel l'année dernière qui avait une
petite passe d'armes
vous avez besoin aussi d'un petit peu de
de soutien de la part des prix nobel
notamment pour faire valider votre
budget oui alors moi je suis très
satisfait puisque c'est la plus grosse
progression du budget depuis 2000
l'année 2000 donc saluera de 6 milliards
de crédits budgétaires de points de
connexion et 850 millions d'euros
supplémentaires de plus donc c'est une
progression très très très fort mais il
faut ça tant les nations aujourd'hui la
compétition se fait sur l'enseignement
supérieur sur la recherche n'y a pas de
craintes à avoir par rapport aux
périmètres de votre ministère non
critique sanctuary voter les crédits ont
été votés en fort pour des chances
l'année seront pas touchés iran pas de
rabot de contreras beau de gel de parce
que là aussi ça qui arrive c'est certain
donc il faut continuer à être vigilants
je vais on n'est jamais sûr de rien une
vigile alimentant cette semaine
également au sénat il ya eu une
discussion importante concernant
évidemment votre ministère sur les
masters ça a été voté au sénat
quelle chance si at il pour que ce soit
votée à l'assemblée avant la fin du
quinquennat
pour le coup je parlais de des
réalisations de des débats ici ces
derniers jours mais au sénat moi je ne
peux que me réjouir du vote de la mise
en place de forme de sélection en master
sélection s'il vaut le mot été placée le
en master 1 et en même temps de
l'organisation du droit la poursuite
d'études pour des gens des étudiants qui
ont la licence ça a été voté à
l'unanimité du sénat
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire quand on
prend le temps de discuter d'être
pragmatique d'être concret on arrive à
convaincre quand on sort du débat
politique de postures qu'on voit parfois
ici ou là pour rentrer dans la vie
concrète à cette amélioration
fin novembre début décembre avec l'aca
figurera bien alors dû jouer profil bas
non là je crois bon vous savez une
proposition de loi d'origine sénatoriale
voté à l'unanimité du sénat
seuls les communistes se sont abstenus
n'ont pas voté contre il n'y a aucune
raison que ce soit pas très vite à
l'assemblée alors on va passer à un
autre sujet à présent qu'une solution
pour calais on voit ça tout de suite
auditionné à l'assemblée nationale
bernard cazeneuve assuré que la
situation était sous contrôle
après l'évacuation du camp de calais il
a fustigé ceux qui demandent un renégat
fier notamment les accords du touquet on
voit ça dans un instant avec vous
thierry mandon parce que la question qui
se pose aujourd'hui il ya eu tous ces
migrants qui ont été dispersés un petit
peu partout sur le territoire français
et on voit qu'il ya un afflux de
migrants notamment à paris notamment
vers stalingrad vers jean jaurès est ce
qu'il faut aujourd'hui évacuer les camps
qui sont en train de se créer un peu
partout dans paris
oui on peut heureusement ne pas de même
nature que d'assurer c'est pas les mêmes
reliés à un afflux de migrants quand
même très important
évidemment c'est pas ça se fait pas d'un
claquement de doigts c'est pas simple à
faire
moi je veux d'abord dire qu'à calais
c'est quand même extraordinaire ce qui
s'est passé il faut fou fou pour nous
annoncer le pire
l'inaction contre l'inaction et les
mesures brutales
tout ça était préparée de très longue
date la france faire l'investissement y
compris matériel pour créer les
conditions de 2,2 la disparition de
calais qu'on n'avait pas fait à l'époque
de 200 garde donc c'est une grosse
réussite
et oui bien sûr les camps sauvages les
bidonvilles de fait qui se développe
partout progressivement vocation est de
démanteler bien sûr il ya le faut il ya
quand même eu des incendies sur les
campements l'impression que la lampe
peut se repeupler quand même assez
facilement cherche ya toujours ici ou là
quelques points négatifs enfin comme g
qui globalement l'aberration de
démantèlement d'un camp de l'importance
de calais qui s'est passé comme il s'est
passé
c'était pratiquement il n'espère et faut
dire bravo à tous ceux qui ont contribué
bien sûr les policiers mais aussi
surtout les associations locales sur le
terrain qu'on fait un boulot formidable
quand il ya la question de l'accueil de
ces migrants dont certains veulent aller
en angleterre
est-ce que vous avez l'impression qu'on
négocie comme il faut avec nos
partenaires britanniques toujours sur
les mineurs isolés de l'union européenne
et notamment sur cette question des
mineurs isolés
les mineurs isolés les anglais le droit
européen et même les décideurs anglaise
stipule qu'ils doivent être accueillis
quand ils ont de la famille en
angleterre
donc on en a sept cette semaine je crois
que c'était un peu plus de 200 et
quelques i qui ont donc déjà été en
angleterre et les quelques cas qui
restent à régler aujourd'hui sont des
mineurs isolés qui devrait rejoindre
l'angleterre
c'est en discussion avec les anglais qui
devrait parce que paul est là qu il faut
pas vraiment les emballe facilite pas
les choses les anglais sont pas pas
facile hein dès qu'il ya un problème qui
se passe en dehors la table c'est ce que
l'on fait hier soir il ministre de
l'intérieur emmanuelle cosse dans un
communiqué où ils ont rappelé les
anglais le responsable alors je vous
propose d'écouter bernard cazenave qui
était auditionné longuement à
l'assemblée nationale dans le cadre de
l'examen budgétaire il a notamment
fustigé ceux qui appellent à renégocier
le fameux accords du touquet qui
régissent nos relations avec la grande
bretagne sur cette question écouter la
renégociation des accords du touquet ça
implique si on les dénonce
deux ans de statu quo avant que ses ago
qui s'est éventuellement être négocié
donc vous aurez deux ans pendant
lesquels vous ont envoyé le signal que
la frontière va devenir devenir pause
mais sans que rien n'ait changé pendant
ces deux ans donc si vous voulez
installer un aspirateur à qu'elle ait
fait cela
est ce que c'est exactement cela qui se
produira deuxièmement si vous voulez que
les passeurs continue envoyé des
migrants et notamment des mineurs isolés
après avoir prélevé sur des sommes
considérables en leur promettant une
traversée hypothétique vers la grande
bretagne dont on sait qu'elles aboutie
depuis le début de l'année à 14 morts
parmi les migrants envoyons aussi ce
signal est-ce qu'il faut toucher à ces
accords du tout du touquet en vertu de
quel la france renforce les contrôles
pour freiner les départs au royaume uni
les états ne surtout pas le faire dans
une période de tension très forte
la pression migratoire en direction des
anglaises mini slater a complètement
raison
si aujourd'hui on cassait ces accords de
bon ce serait forcément de manière
unilatérale et on aurait pendant
longtemps un des règles absolument
changer c'est à dire la situation
d'aujourd'hui empire aujourd'hui on peut
discuter avec les anglais du placement
d'un certain nombre de de réfugiés de
réfugiés binaire et est en période de
crise comme aujourd'hui il faut vraiment
garder ce cap là talibans dont je vous
propose d'ouvrir maintenant une séquence
très politique
mardi à une réunion de groupe edf du
parti socialiste qui était pour le moins
houleuse françois hollande est très
contesté dans son camp et notamment par
un homme claude bartolone jean baptiste
daoulas à huis clos pendant leur réunion
de groupe du mardi 4 députés socialistes
n'ont pas hésité à s'en prendre à
françois hollande
c'est le cas de marcel heureusement j'ai
voulu dire que les militants que je
rencontre sont désappointés désorienté
et donc il ya besoin très rapidement
d'avoir un point d'appui pour pouvoir
parler pour pouvoir dire quelque chose
parce qu'aujourd'hui on est totalement
inaudible toujours à huis clos le
président de l'assemblée nationale
claude bartolone a estimé qu'il y avait
un problème d'incarnation
en clair c'est la personne de françois
hollande qui deviendrait un poids pour
la gauche la publication de ces
confidences dans le livre un président
ne devrais pas dire ça a été la goutte
d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase pour
les députés socialistes et s'ils
soutiennent encore la politique du
gouvernement
beaucoup n'hésitent plus à poser la
question d'un retrait de françois
hollande la question elle est posée elle
n'est pas posée par hugues fourage elle
est posée par les français et par un
certain nombre de dirigeants y compris
le dirigeant du parti socialiste donc je
dire maintenant il faut y répondre il
faut il peut rapidement
on attend tous la position de françois
hollande un certain nombre de deux
parlementaires parce que il n'est pas en
situation ne seront présentés mais
chacun à la correction d'attendre sa
position certains parmi les députés ps
voudrait voir manuel valls se reprendre
le flambeau en 2017
mais le premier ministre est resté
prudent face au groupe socialiste
il s'est simplement déclaré fidèle à la
gauche et à la france demandant est ce
que françois hollande doit se déclarer
au plus vite et il a donné un calendrier
quelqu'un décembre et auquel il a dit
qu'il se tiendrait il est sûr que cette
période d'incertitude sur son éventuelle
candidature facilite pas les choses
donc justement ils devraient pour nombre
terme d'urgence vu la situation des
engagements c'est lui qui en pourquoi il
a fui le 15 décembre n'est pas pour
embêter tout le monde simplement parce
qu'ils considèrent qu'il veut présider
en situation d'être présent la
république le plus longtemps possible et
que je n'en mets donc donc donc à partir
de là c'est son calendrier qui dicte
donc vous avez désarroi dans votre
groupe oui liste oui donc faire leur
donner il faut peut-être régler ce
problème plus vite que ce qu'il n'était
prévu
non parce que le désarroi et il appelle
pas forcément une décision rapprochée de
françois hollande il appelle d'abord des
doutes sur sa candidature même c'est pas
les jambes pas qu'il dise qui va être
candidat plus vite que prévu il veut
certains disent à micro ouvert qu'il
considère que c'est peut-être pas lui
que je te le candidat caisse là donc
c'est sur autre chose
qu'est ce qui pour vous pourrez le faire
renoncer à ce présent à la logique
institutionnelle et la logique politique
veut qu'il soit candidat
il présente la république il est
naturellement comptable d'un bilan et
celui des comptes des comptables devant
le souverain qu'est le peuple donc voilà
c'est cessé après l'arrêt de sa comme
d'un fait très objectif oui mais parce
que mathématiquement non mais c'est la
logique mais en tout cas d'écouté la
logique et écouter ce que je vaux bien
sûr mais ça c'est la logique c'est y
compris en politique on rend des comptes
donc la logique après il décidera s'il
est ou pas en situation si son résultat
est catastrophique
si il advenait que dans le camp de la
gauche de gouvernement est un très bon
candidat peut-être qu'il décidera
finalement de passer son tour
objectivement on a vu les sondages de
cette semaine
quel que soit le candidat de la gauche
de gouvernement c'est le même résultat
ok donc donc donc ça veut bien dire que
c'est pas un problème de qui est
candidat mais que c'était quand même
pourquoi on est candidat au nom de
quelle lecture du quinquennat qui
s'achève au nom de quelles propositions
pour le prochain et je trouve qu'on
passe beaucoup trop de temps sur ces
questions va tirer de quartiers et pas
non mais pas assez sur la lecture
politique qu'est ce qu'on a à dire sur
l'action qu'on a mené depuis cinq ans
est ce qu'on considère toute a été
merveilleux est-ce qu'on est dans
l'autosatisfaction
est-ce qu'on a nous mêmes sur notre
action un regard à la fois positif et
critique donc en quoi et donc parlons
plutôt du fonds les candidatures ça
viendra en son temps quand on est à 4 %
dans les sondages on ne peut que
remonter et françois hollande a du
talent paroles d'alain juppé en meeting
à marseille à propos de françois
hollande est ce que c'est un conseil
avisé
c'est bien vu en tout cas c'est un
expert qui parle parce que un juppé
était il ya quelques années
tombé quasiment aux oubliettes de la vie
politique et le voilà aujourd'hui qui
semble en tête de tous les sondages tant
dans sa primaire que pour l'élection
présidentielle donc il faut écouter ce
que dira juppé a répondu que cette
semaine et on l'avait aussi dans le
reportage
claude bartolone y est allé fort quand
même il a même vu lors de d'un discours
de françois hollande tourner les talons
au moment où le chef de l'état les
prenant parole est ce que c'est bien de
la part de personnalités quasiment
quatrième personnage de l'état
quand je normal je veux pas juger les
comportements je crois qu'il a été
blessé par tel ou tel propos du livre du
président la république dont on se
serait bien passé besoin de ce livre
n'avait évidemment lalanne a pas
d'intérêt d'ailleurs le titre dit tout
donc non c'est pas bien mais je pense
que il coule berlin a parlé d'un
problème d'incarnation qui visait
françois de moi j'ai pas du tout la même
analyse
moi je pense que le problème c'est pas
l'incarnation par françois hollande de
la fonction présidentielle le problème
c'est la fonction présidentielle ce
qu'elle est devenue puis le quinquennat
je pense qu'avec le quinquennat et
c'était vrai déjà pour nicolas sarkozy
quand on se rappelle bien c'était aussi
vrai pour le deuxième mandat de de
jacques chirac le quinquennat a changé
le président de la république quel qu'il
soit qui que ce soit en parle a obligé à
descendre dans l'arène et que c'est ça
qui trouble les français ils vont parler
juste un instant avec notre partenaire
notamment jim scherr à celle qui nous a
rejoints bonjour jim moore michael
bonjour katia bonjour thierry mandon
alors vous le disiez à l'instant selon
vous les problèmes du chef de l'état
sont en partie liées à des cous
institutionnels est ce que vous êtes
comme votre collègue de gouvernement
matthias fekl pour le septennat non
renouvelable et mathias propose à la
commission que claude bartolone avait
réuni à l'assemblée nationale a proposé
aussi cette piste-là moi je les revois
en tout cas ça me semble répondre au
coeur de la problématique qui et comment
on fait pour que le président de la
république
institutionnellement sur guérande
l'essentiel donc sur une durée plus
longue qu'ils soient comptables du long
terme et non pas qu'ils courent derrière
une actualité taux courants qui va
plutôt mais moi je travaillerai plutôt
sur l'article 9 et 19 de la constitution
qui sont les pouvoirs respectifs du
premier ministre et du président je
trouve notamment que la présidence se
parlent président de la répu du conseil
des ministres tir nécessairement le
présent de la public vers la machinerie
gouvernementale actuelle créée et que en
tout cas il ya une réflexion à faire sur
le fait qu'ils se détachent de la vie
quotidienne
pour sortir de la dictature de
l'actualité dont on parle est la
meilleure solution serait justement pas
qu'il soit pas candidat et qui sortent
de là de la course électorale le
président république évidemment c'est
une anthropologie la présidence de la
république
un juge a été montré par des chercheurs
les plus brillants en france on a besoin
d'une assurance vie à la tête de l'état
c'était vrai avec la monarchie c'était
vrai avec l' empire qui vient quelques
années après la révolution française
on a besoin de quelqu'un qui soit la
garantie ultime de la nation et qui
détient que ce que quelqu'un ne soit pas
de droit divin mais qui soit choisi par
le peuple donc l'élection du président
de la république au suffrage universel
c'est anthropologiquement la société
attend ça a besoin de ça le problème
c'est donc cet homme ce surhomme il
s'occupe de quoi il s'occupe de régler
le problème du logement des sans abri
des immigrés du chiffres mensuels du
chômage où il s'occupe de trois ou
quatre priorités nationales plus la
place de la france dans le monde c'est
ça le vrai débat est ma crainte
aujourd'hui y compris au regard de la du
déroulement de la prochaine élection
présidentielle
c'est qu'on demande au président de la
république tous les présents la
république de deux quinquennats de
régler tous les boulons de la société
française de régler tous les problèmes
et ça ça n'est pas possible donc moi je
j'appelle à une redéfinition du rôle
d'un président concentrer sur
l'essentiel
choisi par les français et d'un premier
ministre qui gouverne la grâce à la
plateforme de la prochaine mandature
vous souhaitez me décourage pour peu on
travaille beaucoup avec mathias avec
deux séquelles avec d'eau sur ces sujets
là c'est que crois qu'on est vraiment un
moment où institutionnellement il faut
redessiner définir l'architecturé plongé
-7 et française arnaud montebourg
travailler aussi beaucoup sur ces
questions il travaille justement à
l'élaboration d'une d'un projet de vième
république qui comprendrait selon nos
informations le passage au septennat et
la diminuation la diminution du nombre
de parents tard vous seriez prêt à
soutenir sur un sur un tel projet bah le
passage du septennat je vous ai dit ce
que j'en pensais je suis assez moi je
pense que prem's et les pouvoirs
respectifs du président du premier
ministre
la durée du mandat du président donc
j'ai la mythique désaccord quant à la
diminution département de parlementaires
c'est une tarte à la crème qui fait
plaisir à l'opinion mais peut-être qu'il
faut le faire mais c'est pas le problème
du parlement jolie le prof du parlement
c'est qu'on vote des lois n'importe
comment à vitesse précipité avec peu de
députés qui connaît ça avec des
amendements qui arrivent de partout dont
on connaît même pas l'impact est que si
pour bien fabriquer la loi il faut au
moins deux parlementaires alors 10
millions le nombre de pareloup averti il
ya quelques commençons par la fabrique
de la loi vous avez dit il ya quelques
semaines qu arnaud montebourg pourrait
emporter la primaire est ce que vous le
souhaitez ah non moi je ne souhaite pas
moi je suis restée soutenue en 2011 que
ce gouvernement moi je suis comptable
d'un bilan que j'assume sa de regard
critique sur ce bilan parce que je
considère tout ce qu'on a fait n'est pas
tout réussi je veux voir les 10 heures
supplémentaires mais moi je crois font
mouche
oui bien sûr mais c'est moi qui me
maintient ses les sondages mais le dise
bah oui et je pense que la primaire par
définition c'est une élection qui est
ouverte
et par les temps qui viennent avec donc
la montre est candidat si c'est françois
avec la montée de avec la montée des ddd
vote protestataire
la primaire est gagnée d'avancé pour
personne est ce qu'il a vraiment envie
d'y aller
arnaud montebourg c'est ça il faudrait
vous invitiez je ne sais pas du tout
tout cas il est candidat manifestement
et ils se déplacent non nicolas sarkozy
qui se dit prêt à voter pour françois
hollande face à marine le pen
en cas de duel c'est une bonne chose
selon vous remords tardif remords parce
que c'est la première fois qu'ils nient
ça il a été beaucoup plus ambigu dans
beaucoup de ces déclarations avant
tardive parce que j'y vois une tentative
un peu désespérée essayer de récupérer
dans son camp des électeurs qui lui
reprochent justement d'être beaucoup
trop près du front national politique de
recentrage ça ne suffira pas mais en
tout cas c'est en effet la volonté
probablement de donner à une partie de
son électorat plus centriste dégage
qui n'a pas donné jusqu'à vannes
stratégie pensée non moi je pense que
dans la vie politique fera des boussoles
claire lisible et s'y tenir
on n'habite pas au gré des évolutions
des sondages une question la voilà la
wallonie pardon qui bloque le processus
de négociation du ceta et qui leur
négocié un peu à sa sauce et qu'est ce
que c'est ce que si c'est le signe de
blocage de la machine européenne où
justement sa capacité à s'adapter un peu
de souplesse dans le processus là il
faut c'est pas parce que les la vanille
c'est un tout petit une région qui est
dans un pays il faut mais tous prié ses
positions faut écouter ce que disent les
valves allons les vallons gros qu est ce
qu ils disent qu'ils disent la pente
naturelle vers les accords de
libre-échange systématiser avec des
cours international ça nous inquiète
faut entendre cette inquiétude
voilà le dit quelque chose qui dépasse
largement en 20 secondes
une dernière question qui vous concerne
spécifiques justement vous allez
regretter que votre ministère ne soit
pas équipé de la plate sans fil oui mais
c'est pas que je regrette tout et c'est
pire que ça c'est depuis le premier jour
je me bats pour qu'il les rende horrifié
on leur a semble-t-il au début de
l'année prochaine mais c'est une
aberration y ait jamais eu le wifi
les études les chercheurs du monde
entier via le ministère il demande le
corps dans les ipad wifi si on est
ridicules mais ça veut dire quoi ça
c'est très intéressant je me suis pas
battue juste part qu'adp je me suis
battue parce que pour moi un état
moderne
si un état qui souci des détails de
cette nature là qui sont très symbolique
c'est le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
s'est répandue très bonne semaine